so why don't we just start with the
basic facts so what is investor school
yeah so investor school is a four day
class that we're teaching for the very
first time here in Mountain View across
the street and in the original Y
Combinator of building 320 and it's a
school that's gonna teach the basis the
basics of startup investing um so we
hope people come in person we think
there's a lot of demand so we think
we're hearing a lot of folks who want to
come but also doing a live stream and
we're going to make it a MOOC I
massively open online course just like
we've done in the past with startup
school so we're really excited about the
potential to UM to to give back a whole
bunch of the knowledge that we've gained
at YC over the years and how to be a
really effective angel investor uh-huh
to the community at large so we create
more better happier and what uh what
gave you the impression that folks
needed a school well what gives us the
impression that folks need to the school
is we've seen lots of shall we say not
so effective behavior and approaches to
angel investing and you know not sort of
we're not being conceited and thinking
that we've seen it in ourselves sure
most of us have at one time or another
in the partnership at YC bin angel
investors and so we know all the
missteps we've done them ourselves I
personally have made so many mistakes
angel investing that that I feel if
nothing else qualified to tell you a
whole bunch of things you shouldn't do
so we're trying to help people avoid a
lot of the pitfalls and we're also you
know there's ways to be a better
investor there's ways to be a worse
investor and we think we can help teach
people those and so again make them
better at their job even if it's not a
job better at the discipline of angel
investing and that makes it better for
the companies in whom they're investing
and is there a particular type of person
you're looking for to participate in
investor school like do they need to
have you know been an engineer and had
an egg's
it or they just like have some cash that
they want to invest who are you looking
for well the one qualification is that
you're an accredited investor okay and
the the SEC has a set of rules as to
what comprises accreditation you know in
terms of of income and wealth as long as
you're accredited we want everybody in
fact we actually think this is an
opportunity to add greater diversity to
the ranks of investors so yeah anyone
who's accredited which is a little bit
the equivalent of what you said is you
have some spare cash mm-hmm to invest
that you can afford to lose and you know
you have to be honest about this is a
very high risk investing paradigm so if
you're going to invest in start-up
companies you have to be prepared for
extraordinary upside but also perhaps
more likely downside mm-hmm and are you
giving anyone a certain criteria of what
they should think about it's like this
is an approximate amount of money that
if you're gonna get started angel
investing in the valley you should be
ready to start putting down putting to
work is there a number that you have in
mind I think we'll give some guidelines
as to how to think about creating your
portfolio okay think about doing asset
allocation across that particular yeah
portfolio but how much you invest is a
very personal thing it's sort of how
much you will care about losing how much
upside you want to have what percentage
of a company it's important for you to
own if you think about it that way so I
think the amount that people invest is
incredibly variable there are some
minimums you know you know most people
aren't investing $5,000 when they do
angel investing that does happen but
it's unusual yeah it sort of tends to be
a minimum and the tens of thousands of
dollars up to a maximum of you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars usually
okay so maybe we we ought to walk
through the curriculum and like broad
strokes so we're day one what are you
guys gonna start with well day one we're
gonna start with as you might expect
okay the basics yeah sort of
how and how you should start why you
should start angel investing why do it
what's it about I'm gonna talk a little
bit about the history of investing in
where angel investing came from you know
there didn't used to be such a thing as
an angel there was people pretty much
finance companies on their own
that's a Silicon Valley get started HP
was founded in a garage was 538 dollars
of capital that that that that Dave
Packard and Bill Hewlett scrounge
together to build an audio oscillator
and much of Silicon Valley came from
from graduates of the Hewlett Packard
school of building building products it
was only later that that venture capital
mm-hmm started and you you had a whole
bunch of people coming off the Sand Hill
Road and figuring out that they could
make lots of money I mean there's that
there's an early um venture firm
invested $70,000 in Digital Equipment
Corporation that was one of the earliest
angel investments and they made thirty
five million dollars VC investments
really made 35 million dollars yeah
big-time which is pretty cool 70 yeah
well you know that's the kind of return
that people look at and say I want a
piece of that action so a lot of
companies set up in on Sand Hill Road
and you had sort of classic early VC
from from you know great for starting
Sutter hill and kleiner perkins and
Sequoia all began back in those early
days and and so there was sort of there
was a an intermediate path to raising
capital between putting together your
own money putting money on credit cards
maybe getting friends and family to put
a little money in and then IPO yeah
between adventure came and filled in
some of that but eventually what
happened was it was harder to get
started at the small level and friends
and family who are kind of the original
angels expanded to be people who really
just gave smaller checks you know which
was really the amount needed right in
the very beginning to get a company
ready and able to accept venture
investing so I'm going to tell a little
bit about that and then we're going to
talk I'm gonna have a couple of partners
from YC
go over some of the mechanics of startup
investing that it are a little frankly
mysterious how is it that these weird
convertible notes work used to be when
back in the early days of venture
investing you just bought a share of the
company equity in the corporation now we
have these different instruments that
are much cheaper and faster and simpler
to use but also a little mysterious so
we want to demystify that explain how it
works we've we built up a bunch of
standards yet as to how an angel
investor or any sort of investor will
interact with founders yeah there's
something we call the handshake protocol
which is how you go about sort of
cementing a deal verbally before you do
it on document so we want to cover
things like that so the beginning of the
course is sort of getting the vocabulary
the vocabulary getting the dotting the
i's and cross the t's of how you
actually act as an angel investor how
you should think about when you're
investing how much you're gonna owner
the company how dilution works how cap
tables work all those basics that kind
of you know you you sort of run into it
no one tells you what's this document
there yeah I mean but what about even
before that what about an evaluating a
company if you're a non-technical person
who wants to invest in software yeah
we're gonna get into that sort of in
right in the very beginning question is
so you want to invest in a company how
do you learn about the company well yeah
there's actually a simple answer to that
you meet with the founders and talk to
them so we're gonna quite extensively go
into when you go into a meeting with
founders how should you conduct that
mean how should you think about the
founder if I'm meeting with you and
we're talking about your company how do
I make judgments about whether this is a
company I want to invest in how should I
think about that okay so you want to
kind of help people through that exact
answer that exact question so yeah let's
get specific on some of these like
you're meeting with a founder for the
first time what's a red flag when you're
like say there are two or three
co-founders you're talking to them about
a product and it's just I don't know
what's something that you might spot
that you're like I don't know if I want
to put money into this startup
well for me the very first thing comes
with sort of how I read the founders
belief in what they're doing okay if you
have this passion people usually talk
about passion I remember listening to
Mike Moritz talk about this once then he
talked about it being at a different
level like almost an obsession with what
you're building and why you're building
it you have to care so deeply that
everything that's going to happen to you
as a start-up founder will be something
that you will think nothing of
overcoming because that's the sure thing
you know that if you don't have the
resilience you need the toughness you
need the determination you need the
belief you need it none of the other
things matter nothing else how big the
opportunity is how much of competition
there is or isn't how much money you
raise how smart you are none of that
matters because it won't happen so
that's where ice that's where I start
and and if I can't get past the Hat so
if I don't I don't get that that sense
and are you are you kind of laying a
little trap here in there to see if
they'll you know bite on something like
oh I don't know if they're quite
confident enough or is it just this like
vibe someone has what what do you
actually saying traps and underhanded
and I don't I personally I don't throw
the devil's eye well yeah everyone gets
different styles yeah I'm very direct
and so what I like to do is I like to
push okay so there's and it's easy to do
after a while because every single idea
has a million things that could possibly
go wrong with it and half of those will
yeah so so you talk about those and you
see how they react to it okay how they
you know as you push on them and you say
well you know how could this possibly
work you know you want to you want to
provide ride-sharing services to seniors
you know they don't really use their
phones how are you gonna do that Craig
how are you gonna and you know you start
to push on those ideas and so I
I think that a certain amount of this
you can't teach yeah it's experience you
know as partners in YC we've all talked
to hundreds not thousands of companies
yeah right yeah but we can we can I
think illuminate the process and get
people started on the right foot and
that's I think the way we should think
about this it's a short course yeah
it's four days two classes per day so at
sort of eight sessions total over that
four day period it's not it's not you
know of six month graduate school
investing I don't even know what you
would cover in that it's enough I think
to put you on the right road to becoming
a fantastic angel investor and that's
our goal okay create more fantastic
angel investors in fantastic me someone
do they make the right choices for
themselves they help companies need more
they have a better relationship with
companies they make their decisions in a
more effective timely fashion yeah it's
not just spray-and-pray like show up to
demo day spend two hundred thousand
dollars and then hopefully I mean that
can be okay it's a terrible thing for
companies generally to get that kind of
cash yeah but I think it's much more
useful for companies to get thoughtful
investors right who invests for the
right reason and who you know are not
painful later who understand the the
quid pro quo that's going on when you
invest him when you get a piece of a
company and and how you should be
interacting with that CEO and founding
team henceforth so from a personal
perspective do you only invest in
companies where you feel like you can
add more value than your money or are
you okay just putting money into
something you think is attractive but
you don't really know about the space a
lot of people say that they'll only
invest in companies you know there are
all types a lot of people say that and
then they put money all over the place
well there's what you say in what you do
but there's all different there's
there's there's there's probably as many
different styles of angel investing as
angel yeah me personally I think
I invest when I get excited about a
company okay and it may be a little
egotistical but I kind of believe that I
can always help a company because I've
seen so many company I've been doing
this for yeah coming up on seven years
now and I've been angel investing
thirteen years now this being why I see
an angel investing for longer than that
so as those uh as those Insurance
commercials go I've seen a thing or two
yeah yeah right
so so I kind of believe that but I think
that's separate from if like if you're
talking to me and I say oh my gosh this
guy's amazing or this girl's amazing
this is an idea and you know I'm gonna
invest yeah and do I believe I'll be
able to help you you have a you know
there's another perspective that's
important to have as an angel investor
angel investors can in limited cases
have substantive impact on the companies
in which they invest you know mostly
their impact is marginal yep minimum you
might meet with a company once a year
twice a year maybe and you might give
them some really good advice they're
building the company and sometimes I you
know I think angels or I've heard angels
take way too much credit again sometimes
angels are very helpful and I'd like to
think that I've been quite helpful to
the company that I've worked with but
they're building the company and so you
know if there's if there's a pile of
credit for success 99.9 percent goes to
them and their team and and and
sometimes to bigger investors who spend
a lot more time with them than angel
investors who go on the board and meet
with them every quarter or more
frequently err and help them recruit and
most angels don't spend that much time
doing that hmm okay at times they do and
some do more than others but for the
most part I you know I I'm honest with
myself and City and know that like words
I can be pretty helpful the main reason
to invest and it's good to be helpful
and it's good to be that kind of
investor but the main reason is because
you believe yeah and that's why I invest
in so that going back to the vetting
process I heard an of all
Brava con in a startup investing talk
from angel conflict years ago on the
venture hacks blog I think he said
something like it wouldn't be strange if
you met with a hundred companies before
you made your first angel investment do
you have a rule of thumb around that
no no so it could be the first one yep
okay I'll have a different rule of thumb
analysis it wouldn't be strange well
what I would argue from personal
experience is that you oughta wait just
because it's hard to calibrate yeah in
the beginning but at this point I have
no count like I'll meet lots of
companies and I know when and I do think
like my calibrations done I know when
I'm interested okay in some combination
of the founder the idea the opportunity
the execution they've had up to the end
yeah all those things but but it is true
in the very beginning before you've made
your first angel investment calibrate so
do spend I don't know if it's a hundred
or ten or fifteen you should hmm this
being said it's being said there are one
of the reasons people angel invest is
surely because they want to be Professor
Horowitz at Stanford who invested in
Google and became a billionaire doing
that it's nice to be college you know
billionaire college professor and those
companies don't come along very often
and so if for whatever reason you
believe that the first company you talk
to just might be the next Google or the
next day or B&B right it it will be
painful to let that go yeah so if you
got that belief no I do think that you
know the probability is low that you
ever seen one of those if you see if you
saw one the very first one would be it'd
be a strike of lightning but but it goes
back to what you said already like you
have to be able to throw the money away
right so if the first company you see
not throw it away but
you know that you know what I mean right
do I have to be prepared
yeah to zero out that investment in fact
you know my default position when I
invest in a start-up is that that
investment is not worth zero it's not
like if I if I put pick a number $25,000
exactly in a company and and then I
track that yeah its value is zero until
I have more information that it's not
exactly yeah you have to have so whether
it's the first investment or the 20th
investment you're still gonna feel them
know that pressure when you're about to
write a check and you're like oh don't
know if this is it but eventually you're
gonna have to pull the trigger
so what other things how else do you
help someone mentally prepare to become
an angel investor what like mental
models you offer what do you recommend
one of the things we're gonna do in this
course which I'm pretty excited about is
we're going to get four pretty
well-known yeah pretty successful angel
investors okay to come in and kind of
tell their stories a little bit to give
give what I call angelic advice about
how they dealt with that I do think the
bottom line is you gotta do it early and
you have to meet with a bunch of
founders you have to think about their
companies usually it's a good idea to
invest in some space that you have some
familiarity with em hmm so you can
actually hopefully make a more educated
judgment okay and then and then go for
it yeah go for it or not and you'll get
better at it
so what else what else is on the
curriculum what else do we have to look
forward to uh well okay so I've taught
that not much because again it's a
pretty short cricket but we're gonna
talk a little bit about how to be a good
investor we've talked I brought that up
earlier yeah it's it's actually
shockingly easy to be a terrible
investor and so we want to talk about
what it means to be a good investor and
how you should think about that and how
you should interact with companies and
what companies need and want from you as
an angel investor and that that goes
from first meeting to you know whatever
whatever rhythm you have meeting with
the company once you're actually an
investor if at all some some some
investors just want to invest and like
you know write me a check when it's all
over right but but most want to sort of
get updates and definitely and talk to
the the the CEO that's part of the fun
of it by the way and watching Washington
progress I just got to go and talk to a
YC company that's doing great I mention
them but what I also made an angel
investment and in and and you know you
know if I'm two people now there are 50
people and there I've got a big
valuation and they have all sorts of
problems and and they're doing
incredibly well and it's exciting it's
just that's a really fun thing but so I
want to talk about that but maybe the
last thing I'll say about the curriculum
for the course that I'm excited about is
we want to talk a little bit about
investing in the 21st century because it
hasn't changed I was talking about HP
back in 1957 in 1937 excuse me that's
when that's when HP was founded in 37
but venture capital really started in 57
and 60 and then sort of angels came in
in the subsequent decades yeah things
changed a lot once the 2000s the 21st
century came probably the first big
change was Y Combinator was accelerators
rethinking how people did early stage
investing well it's changing again you
mentioned avocado he launched this thing
called AngelList
and there's something called Kickstarter
so AngelList brings people and companies
together in a really unique online way
to to invest in in sort of with a
different paradigm than than before as Y
Combinator was a different paradigm but
investing it's investing in bulk right
we invest in a whole bunch of startups
all at once but there's new stuff
happening you know about this right
there's there's there's I cos there's
initial coin offerings companies are
changing the way they think about the
availability of capital the SEC is
looking hard this right now it's complex
so why don't talk a little bit about how
the space is changing and evolving
another thing I didn't mention was that
I sort of talked about this history and
in in if sort of a not very
chronological way and so I'll get you
that other things that happened sort of
after YC sort of began this accelerator
crazes who became a lot more angels out
there mm-hmm and the angels started to
professionalize and some of the angels
who were most experienced angels became
what we called at the time super angels
okay or micro VCS and they started to
creating funds so then you had a little
bit of fragmentation of VC where there
was a bunch of early stage and then
series a and then growth after that and
then and then you had a whole bunch of
of evolution of that where VC started
doing both early stage and growth
sometimes in the same fund strangely
which I don't necessarily think is a
great idea so there was this there's
this the I I don't know fragmentation is
the right term I used it before but this
is you know diversification of styles of
professional investors professional
investors meaning someone who has
limited partners who have who have who
are investing other people's money
besides their own and and so that's
changed a lot in the very first century
but certainly these the the new ways to
raise money the crypto oriented
techniques are pretty radical mmm-hmm
radical in that like so early there's a
equal amount of money and ICL's being
raised by startups as venture money
that's crazy
so fast for sure don't really believe
it's sustainable and there's a lot of
crap of course yeah
certainly a lot of fraud out there too
so you know buyer beware mm-hmm
but but the world is shifting and
changing I mean absolutely radical II
rapidly so we want to talk a little bit
about that so people are kind of up to
speed with some of what's happening and
that's kind of the gamut of the course
where we're covering a lot of the
fundamentals some insider looks at that
how you become an angel investor and how
you think about deal flow on portfolios
and making your decisions and and then
maybe a little bit of a look towards
towards the future and where we're going
okay awesome so we would be remiss if we
didn't talk about your personal angel
investing experience to share some
advice with people just to give them a
taste before they sign up for investor
school so before you said the good and
bad habits of being an angel investor
let's talk about those specifically what
does it mean to be a good angel investor
so this qualitative thing is good it
like good can mean a few things that can
mean that you're actually good to your
companies they can actually mean you get
a good return okay so yeah they like
trying to answer kind of both of them
yeah I think to be a a good angel
investor first is you you have to follow
your passion invest in what you care
about
but don't be emotional you'll make a lot
of bad decisions if you're emotional so
it is it is a cold hard cash investing
decision and you should think about it
that way yeah you should learn how to
say no and learn how to say no
explicitly and kindly and with as many
real reasons as you can mm-hmm
I'll get back to that in a sec but
that's part of being a good investor to
two companies if you if you meet with me
and I say I'm thinking about it Craig
you seem to have a pretty good idea I'll
get back to you and I never get back to
you sometimes investors do that because
it's just hard to say
dude no yeah and so you have to learn
how to do that say no sometimes as I
said you should be as honest as you can
especially if it can be helpful
sometimes you can't sometimes it's
because you know I didn't believe in you
I don't think you were smart enough I
didn't think you were strong enough I
didn't think all these things that I'm
not really gonna say in an email to you
so you have to come up with some way to
gracefully say I'm not interested but
remember what we talked about and eval
said you have to meet with a hundred
companies at least ten or twenty or
thirty and certainly you want deal flow
and that's another thing about being a
good angel investor you need deal flow
find a way to get deal flow
we'll talk about that if you don't have
deal flow you'll take the first thing
you get you'll talk to me I'll invest
please take my money right so you're in
a micro-level you wouldn't necessarily
be wrong either if your deal flow is
only ten companies a year you may still
pick the best one but it may still fail
you might just need it which is which is
who know what you're saying which is
being wrong in the macro sense but
you're like a locally right but that
doesn't do you any good exactly that's
why you do need more to see but but
again I do think these sinks down alone
you have to look at whether you believe
the opportunity is there and that you
have a founder in front of you who has a
has some probability of winning in in
the fight for that opportunity so so be
rigorous and organized and dedicated and
you know even if you're dabbling and I
think most angel investors dabble
they're not professional yeah this
course by the way is not meant to teach
people to be professionals I don't
expect real venture capitalists will
come and take the course I expect angels
who are investing their own money and
who are doing this because they enjoy
working with founders because they have
causes that they care about because they
want to see innovation in the world
because they want to see change mm-hmm
those are all really good reasons and
those are good reasons to invest but you
have to temper that because you know I
wouldn't recommend just investing in
change with no hope for return right you
can if you're really willing to throw
away whatever amount of money you're
investing and I would never gain say
that if you're doing this because
there's some possibility of making a
difference creating change even if
you're not that concerned about the
return that's fine but most angels wants
some kind of return I would also say you
know most angel investors should ignore
the little stuff because when your angel
investing if you're going for a 7.6
percent return to try to beat the stock
market you're in the wrong game right
right it's a game of big wins so don't
sweat the little stuff
you know don't run your founders through
the wringer as they're shutting down and
try to extract some bit of blood from a
stone where there isn't any it doesn't
matter yeah it doesn't matter in fact if
you think about it if you act like a
jerk to a founder that might be even if
that gets you an extra 50% of your
return your investment back somehow that
might actually cost you way more in the
long term because the way you get deal
flow is because some founder says to
another founder you should take Jeff
rosten's money because he's a good
person to have on your cap table right
so my advice is be a good person to have
on someone's cap table be that person
say Ron Conway you want his money
he will help you he's not a jerk he will
be on your side yeah it's so
relationship based something I didn't
fully realize until I moved out here was
how important optionality is when people
are investing it's not uncommon for
someone to say no at one point and then
say yes
later down even if they have to pay a
premium for that and I think that's a
difficult thing because on the
relationships I've done that lots of
times I mean yeah you know one thing we
tell founders here and it's that the
reverse is true for investors yeah
there's no no forever
it's not now exactly not now I'm not
ready you're not ready whatever but the
thing that messes with your head is when
someone says not now in other what in
other areas of life you're just like oh
they're politely telling me to go away
and never but here not now often means
not now like call me in 18 months when
you're raising money again yeah and so
yeah but there there is you know the
fact is most angel investors don't get a
bite at the later rounds they might get
a bite later on during this round and
you think about it but but don't I mean
there's there's a look one other thing I
will say not to do as an investor which
is don't try to be the last money in
because you don't have any confidence in
yourself so
some of the worst investor behavior is
to say hi guy like you I like your
company you're raising a million dollars
I'll put a hundred thousand dollars in
as soon as you've raised nine hundred
thousand because you're useless the fact
the matter is once you Craig have raised
nine hundred thousand dollars you don't
need me and I have demonstrated right
that in there that you don't need me
yeah right yeah you'll fill it in with
someone else and fill it almost someone
who's more useful who who has more
courage behind their conviction totally
be the kind of investor who has enough
courage to say you've raised zero I'll
be the first money yet I like you that
much and on the on the strategic side
for for you personally what have been
some of the best moves that you were you
were unsure about in the beginning but
then later on you're like oh maybe I
kind of called it there
thing that worked out pretty cool huh
well the best example of that is one of
my earliest angel investments and I did
it for the wrong and the right reasons
the wrong reason was the woman who was
running this company mm-hmm was an old
friend
someone I had worked with for years
years before and that's a terrible
reason to invest in someone except that
she's awesome and I've done both way
like sometimes you like feel pretty good
and your investment Lee because they're
a friend and it's not a good choice this
one in this case it was the right reason
but like the space was really tough it
was in wireless networking and geez
there was so much competition they were
a small wireless networking company and
they had some kind of cool technology
but she wasn't even a founder she became
the CEO she'd been a founder before she
I know she's like nails good but you
know I didn't know the founders very
well and it was this hardware thing and
you know some software and oh my gosh
and so I only invested a little bit and
that was so far the only company that
has IP owed there yeah and I made a
really good return on my investment so
that one worked out okay really nicely
and it took and it was one of those
things where I was like God's never
gonna have
it's never gonna like and I kind of sort
of lost track until I kind of wait I
woke up one day and they'd IPO I got to
notice that I had public company stock
and I was I was sort of literally
shocked
was there a learning on the positive
side where you're like oh this is a
pattern that I might be able to match
again or did you just get lucky and you
know a good person Hatari like it was
because I knew a good person yeah I
invested in that person but aside from
all the all the other warning signs like
this space are you kidding me I found
this I don't know that well but like
this great person is really smart and
really capable has done this before it's
running the company yeah invest in that
all day long okay
so I did want to ask you you hope you've
had success with startup investing angel
investing where you didn't necessarily
know if it was gonna pan out obviously
you never know what a mistakes you've
made
oh um I actually think the appropriate
question is which mistakes haven't I
made because I've made them all
I've invested in family don't do that
yeah I invested without thinking it
through very much don't do that I
invested in spaces where I really had no
freaking clue at all about it and I just
did it because and don't do that I
invest in spaces because someone I
thought was smart invested there and
sometimes that's a good thing to do but
I didn't put enough thought into it I've
been fooled by founders I thought they
were better than they were I've invested
in founders in a technical in a space
that demanded great technical know-how
that didn't have great technical
know-how I've invested in founders where
I didn't believe in them and then
decided not to invest and then was
persuaded by short-term results that I
was wrong but I wasn't mmm do you often
invest internationally almost never
almost never I have invested
international YC companies sometimes so
I shouldn't say almost never when I was
investing pre YC or outside of YC I
haven't
okay it's too complicated yeah I can't
get my head around it
talk about an investing play in in
ecosystems you don't understand and I
mostly try to invest in places where I
have an understanding or a belief system
I don't have to be deep into it I will
invest in in in CRISPR companies yeah
because I you know I'm not a biologist
but I think CRISPR is arnaud
shatteringly important technology I
wrote up I wrote it up absolutely about
that just because it's so cool I
wouldn't claim to be an expert and and
synthetic biology in general I have
believed for half a decade now is going
to be incredibly important before I even
know anything about CRISPR but just the
idea that you could start to think about
yeah
programming the tree of life in fact a
conviction that I had way back then that
we're going to figure out how to do it
it just kind of happened really quickly
where like the ability to do gene
editing at a very detailed level came
about thanks to bacteria yeah very much
bacteria it's so cool amazing yeah
and but I'm sure you're gonna have
international angel investors come in
right and so definitely there are them
all over the place right so I don't
think it's different though I mean right
let me caveat that sure it's different
but III think the set of things we're
going to talk about are generic and will
will be true for them as well here's
it's a good point you make probably
assuming this course goes well and we
teach it again in the future we'll think
about whether we need to add more about
what it what how you should think about
investing he's a u.s. investor and
international companies or it is an
international company as an
international investor in international
companies in countries in your own
company in your own country or say
investing in US companies there's
certainly a lot of international
investors who come and invest in Western
companies on demo day
but that's the beauty of its you know
this is our experiment to learning
experience for us as well as for the
students and hopefully assuming it goes
well we'll improve it and do it again
next year
that's great why should someone go if
they want to apply they should go well
it's the application is going to open on
Thursday and they I hope I get this
right they should go to investor startup
school org okay
and we'll also post it on the blog - all
right thanks Jeff
thanks a lot Craig nice talking to you
you do
you